bonjour si les accies bill merci
beaucoup d'être en direct ce matin sur
rtl france il y a un an jour pour jour
premier confinement inédit qui était
appliquée en france quel bilan vous
faites vous de cette gestion de la crise
par le gouvernement
ben moi je la trouve depuis un an
effectivement on est confronté à
plusieurs problèmes et moi ce qui me ce
qui me saute un petit peu aux yeux c'est
que chaque fois contre une solution eh
bien il ya un problème qui arrivent par
rapport à cette solution
donc il vaut quand même bien doté c'est
que si on compare par rapport aux
épidémies cas puis à voir que quelqu'un
d'autre continents notre pays a pu subir
vidéo durant le siècle dernier on a
plutôt été très réactifs et on peut
d'abord salué des ligaments idée jeudi
on a trouvé des solutions
il ya des problèmes par rapport à des
solutions mais comme on a comme une idée
la science est une rame pour pour
trouver des solutions qu'il faille
stream et même si à court terme on voit
des choses on peut que constater que
tout va parfaitement
j'ai trouvé qu'on peut comme ça lui est
là la recherche de manière très brève au
bout d'un an on a les différents aux
problèmes à trouver une solution alors
la france a montré aussi ces retards 1
quasiment surtout par rapport à ses
voisins européens il ya eu les masques
les tests les vaccins les autotests même
qui devrait arriver cette semaine pour
le grand public rien pour l'instant
alors que l'allemagne les ai déjà
est-ce que ça a mis en lumière aussi les
failles de la france en matière
d'industrie non je pense que c'est pas
tellement niveau moi ce qui m'a surpris
c'est plus au niveau des normes
effectivement on est on est un pays qui
est très administrée où il ya plusieurs
niveaux décision est bien quelque part
il faut mettre tout ça en branle pour ce
pour faire bouger le système moi un truc
que je retiens c'est le fait que par
exemple par un protest
on a eu des tests qui existait au niveau
chez les animaux il a fallu casser la
frontière entre les tests vétérinaire et
est humain donc pour moi c'est pis en
place de normes
je pense que
la france aussi on peut manque un petit
peu de culture scientifique donc les
français c'est important c'est qu'ils
aient confiance par rapport à ce qu'on
fait et la confiance ça demande une
réflexion sa demande le consulter et il
vaut mieux prendre quelques jours
quelques semaines de retard
plutôt que produisit décision alors il
ya de possibles restrictions qui sont
discutées ce matin un conseil de défense
hier le premier ministre l'a clairement
évoqué il a parlé d'une troisième vague
jean castex écoutez le effectivement
quand vous le savez mesdames et
messieurs nous sommes dans ce qui
ressemble à une forme de troisième vague
caractérisée par des variants nombreux
qui s'est en tout cas le cas du variant
dit britannique prend une place de plus
en plus importante alors vous êtes dans
le rhône mais ce confinement l'île de
france il était prévisible selon vous
est-ce qu'il arrive un peu tardivement
s'il arrive bien sûr non non je pense
pas il faut s'adapter ce qui vous
reprendre c'est que depuis un an et demi
pour moi là la crise est plutôt bien
gérée depuis un an on est sur une ligne
de crête
il ne faut pas tomber d'un côté vers le
voeu d'un gant dans la crise sanitaire
et de l'autre côté il ne fallait pas
tomber dans la critique de milk est
maintenant dans la crise un petit peu
psychologique par rapport à l'état
psychologique de la population on est
sur une ligne de crête il ya huit ans il
ne l est pas droite on effectivement
tutrice plein tous les mois on apprend
de de nouvelles choses par rapport au
virus par rapport aux variants
maintenant à pau mutants ce qu'il faut
c'est s'adapter et je trouve que depuis
un an on s'est plutôt bien adapté au
niveau économique
tu lis au niveau scientifique il faudra
au niveau scientifique même si
actuellement il ya des soucis par
rapport au vaccin
c'est comme une fois scientifique
extraordinaire d'avoir des solutions
comme ça au bout d'un an donc on
s'adapte ou bien la france a ce côté
effectivement et je pense que c'est
important
il faut absolument que les gouvernants
et la confiance des français il faut
qu'il manque et solutions qu'on apporte
des vaccins et la confiance des français
donc il faut mieux par rapport à qui mon
retrait parle de ce résultat
il vaut mieux prendre deux jours ce qui
m'aurait fichiers au bout
le problème est qu'on arrive vraiment
avec mellie francon deux côtés on a tout
vérifié le risque d'asthme nicky et car
il est un film intime donc le principe
c'est de continuer à vacciner mais plus
globalement vous parliez de confiance un
récent sondage montre que 64% des
français ne font pas confiance justement
à l'exécutif pour gérer cette crise
c'est dû à quoi selon vous une mauvaise
communication
non ce que je pense que tout le monde
est chaud depuis un an on va de surprise
en surprise et donc par rapport à une
surprise par rapport à ces modifications
effectivement les gens se posent des
questions le moi je vois et tout les
jours je voit lorsque je discute avec
les gens je je je comprends pas bien ce
chiffre de 104 % dans ce sens où les
français sont en tout cas ce que je
rencontre trouve que c'est plutôt bien
géré et séduisent chaque fois la
réflexion c'est germain pas à leur place
je m'apprête à votre place pour gérer
cette crise et antonymes il trouve pile
au circuit tout bien des choses donc par
rapport à ce chiffre jeu en tout cas
c'est pas les gens que je croise dans la
rue alors dans le rhône également le
taux d'incidence a tendance à augmenter
même s'il n'ya on peut pas parler de
saturation dans le rhône à l'hôpital
faut-il prendre des mesures rapidement
selon vous et au niveau local les lycées
c'est le principe de la ligne de crête
la ligne de crête ce qu'il faut c'est
bien évidemment pas tomber dans la crise
sanitaire donc pour moi estimant les
livres animations c'est un sujet mais
effectivement on voit quelques baffes
on fait des évacuations sanitaires qui
permettent de libérer un petit peu et
pitau donc il faut pour moi c'est le il
faut qu' on est toujours des lits de
réanimation libre ça c'est la première
chose et en même temps il faut pas
désespérer les français et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il ne faut pas trop confiné
je trouve que l'exemple de dunkerque est
assez intéressant où on a confiné
fictivement week-end ç'a permis qui
manteau de faire tomber le dossier danse
de manière importante de diviser par
deux au bout de quinze jours donc on
peut éventuellement imaginer le fait que
effectivement qu'on soit conçois qu'on
soit confiné le week-end
toi qui ne se mission alors on m'a parlé
des élections si vous voulez bien
françois bayrou veut un référendum au
moment des régionales en juin prochain
sur la question de la proportionnelle un
peu agacée d'ailleurs que le président
emmanuel macron n'est pas tenu sa
promesse
écoutez votre président ce à quoi nous
sommes confrontés c'est le conservatisme
éternel des forces politiques qui
veulent garder le pouvoir pour elle des
forces politiques majoritaires qui
croient qu'elles vont le rester
j'ai proposé un référendum le jour du
deuxième tour des élections législatives
pour que ce soit réglé
on m'a dit c'est trop tôt et maintenant
c'est trop tard
alors que pensez vous de cette
déclaration est ce que cette question
serait de nature à remettre en cause
l'alliance du modem avec la république
en marche pour la présidentielle de 2000
22h précisant puisque c'est pas le cas
pour les régionales on est on est bien
et le modem est très bien dans la
majorité présidentielle ont
effectivement la proportionnelle et
c'est un des sujets sont des sujets qui
n'ont des centristes et ça depuis des
décennies le principe c'est comment
faire pour que les français se sentent
mieux représentés à l'assemblée
nationale
actuellement on nie d'abord en prison à
public e j ai finalement le chef d epuis
kif
maintenant c'est au niveau législatif
comment faire en sorte que chaque
français puisse se déplacer pour aller
voter et je dire à l'assemblée nationale
j'ai quelqu'un effectivement qui portent
m'avoir et c'est tout l'intérêt qu'ils
mangent les lèche-bottes les lèche
proportionnelle ça permettra aux gens de
mus d'abord se déplacer ou à chaque fois
on dit qu'il ya beaucoup d'absentéisme
sassareu motiverait dense dans le sens
oui j'oubliais il vaut mieux moi je vis
toujours l'assemblée nationale il vaut
mieux que le débat se tienne à
l'assemblée nationale que dans la rue
donc c'est pour ça que la
proportionnelle et est pour nous la
solution
après en terme de calendrier et
j'entends bien c'est vrai que on avoue
on voulait faire une réforme de la
constitution et du mode électoral
souvenez-vous six mois ya deux ans
s'était bloquée par certains événements
maintenant effectivement remet le sujet
sur la table pour moi c'est jamais trop
tard dans le sens où chaque fois qu'il
ya un changement de mode électoral
ça s'est toujours fait à un an de son
temps celle ci a fait général de gaulle
c'est ce qu'a fait donc pour moi il est
toujours temps de modifier on sait
on a jusqu'au mois de juin pour faire
maintenant faut-il que l'assemblée
nationale
et ça c'est notre travail faut-il de
trouver une majorité qui puisse voter ce
texte sassari valley au combat si on
sait que ça sera pas votée donc à nous
de convaincre nos collègues députés de
toutes tendances de la tendance dans la
majorité ou dans l'opposition pour
trouver une majorité pour pour
activement appliquer cette prochaine
merci beaucoup cyrille isaac sibille
d'avoir répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france
merci